all right thank you Ron that ballpark
has already won many awards as a minor
league French or a ballpark they're
exciting news for sure today big
outstanding question of course there
who's going to pay for all this 8 news
now investigator Kyle Payne digging into
that all day following the money he
joins us now live hey Kyle
yes I'm at the future site of the Las
Vegas A's not too far from T-Mobile
Arena there's an old saying the answer
to all your questions is money there are
a lot of logistical concerns and all
that could take a lot of time to sort
out but the bottom line of whether the
Oakland A's and the powers that be in
Clark County and or Nevada are able to
strike a deal lies well in the bottom
line the eight news now investigators
confirmed that the Oakland A's are
committed to spending at least a billion
dollars to finance this project but that
means they would be looking for Nevada
to somehow come up with a half a billion
dollars using tax offsets and any other
income to pay for bonds they may have to
get creative because unlike other sports
Ventures here the governor has said no
new taxes such as the room tax that was
used to pay for Elysian stadium and I
spoke with economic analyst General
Aguero who says there's a lot of money
to go around that will help pay for this
deal
this is all takes the taxes that are
essentially utilized that are generated
by the project and reinvest those
dollars back into the project so not
only does that provide an economic
opportunity to utilize the dollars the
taxes that would that are generated as a
result of a 1.5 billion dollar Stadium
being constructed and a stadium that
would host 81 baseball games at a
minimum as well as other special events
that's a significant amount of money and
and when you include the development of
a essentially baseball Village if you
want to think about that or Sports
Entertainment District around that it
adds additional funds
I received a statement from the state
senate Democratic caucus which is kind
of lukewarm on this it says the Senate
Majority Leader Nicole cannizzaro has
been briefed on the outline of a
proposal and quote she appreciates the
interest the A's have shown in Las Vegas
however she is not committed to
supporting any deal nor would she
without seeing detailed legislative
language and discussing it with her
caucus I also spoke with Clark County
Commissioner chairman Jim Gibson he says
the A's have a lot of questions it's
going to be costly no matter which way
you look at it reporting live Kyle Payne
8 News Now